il y a tout juste une semaine la
direction d'Alcatel Lucent annoncé la
fermeture du site de véisi le groupe
prévoit la suppression de plus de 5000
emplois dans le monde dont près de 1500
postes en France ce matin 350 salariés
d'Alcatel à vellisie ont rejoint 200
collègues au centre de nosé à Villarceau
dans les son pour une assemblée générale
c'est sur ce site que les employés
éilinois devrai être transférés après la
fermeture des locaux de
véis là-bas déjà on a on est allé
visiter la cantine puisque on nous dit
que c'est là-bas qu'on va devoir
s'installer si si le site de Vézy ferme
donc ben déjà on voit qu'aujourd'hui euh
bah le site il est pas prêt à nous
accueillir il y a pas les bâtiments il y
a pas les infrastructures donc on sait
que si jamais on doit aller là-bas ben
ça va être la galère pendant des années
en attendant que que le site soit soit
prêt à nous accueillir et puis on a fait
une une assemblée générale des salariés
pour pour expliquer qu'il faut vraiment
qu'on se mobilise et qu'on se mobilise
vite et fort parce que la direction elle
elle va frapper vite et fort
aussi